selamat datang kembali di Understanding Quantum Information and Computation, nama saya John Watrous dan saya adalah direktur teknis pendidikan di IBM
Quantum. Ini adalah pelajaran ke-10 dari seri ini dan merupakan pelajaran kedua di unit ketiga yang membahas tentang
formulasi umum dari informasi kuantum. Pelajaran ini membahas tentang channel, yang merepresentasikan perubahan dalam
sistem yang menyimpan informasi kuantum. Ini mencakup operasi yang berguna seperti yang dilakukan oleh
unitary gate dan quantum circuit, serta perubahan yang mungkin ingin kita hindari seperti noise. Kita juga bisa mendeskripsikan pengukuran
sebagai channel dan itu akan kita bahas di pelajaran berikutnya. Istilah channel berasal dari
teori informasi yang antara lain mempelajari kapasitas pembawa informasi dari channel komunikasi yang
penuh noise. Jadi kalau kita bicara soal channel, kita berpikir secara abstrak tentang channel komunikasi.
Mungkin terasa agak aneh membayangkan sebuah komputasi yang rumit sebagai sebuah channel komunikasi, tapi kita butuh sebuah
kata untuk merujuk pada gagasan umum tentang sebuah proses yang mengubah informasi dengan cara tertentu. Dan mau tidak mau, kata
channel pun bertahan, tidak diragukan lagi karena dampak besar dari teori informasi, dan khususnya
karya Claude Shannon di tahun 1940-an, terhadap informasi dan komputasi kuantum. Berikut ini adalah gambaran umum dari
pelajaran ini. Kita akan mulai dengan dasar-dasarnya, termasuk definisi dari apa itu channel, serta bagaimana operasi unitary dalam formulasi yang disederhanakan
dari informasi kuantum bisa dideskripsikan sebagai channel. Kita juga akan membahas fakta bahwa kombinasi cembung dari channel-channel adalah channel, dan kalau kamu
bertanya-tanya kenapa gagasan konveksitas ini terus muncul, itu karena memang ini adalah gagasan matematika yang sangat fundamental dalam teori
informasi kuantum. Kita juga akan melihat beberapa contoh channel, khususnya qubit channel yang akan muncul dari waktu
ke waktu sepanjang sisa pelajaran ini. Di bagian kedua pelajaran ini, kita akan membahas tiga cara berbeda untuk merepresentasikan channel
secara matematis, dan secara khusus kita akan membahas representasi Stinespring, representasi Kraus, dan Choi
yang dinamai berdasarkan tiga orang yang karyanya penting dalam pengembangan representasi-representasi yang berbeda ini. Dan di bagian ketiga dan
terakhir pelajaran, kita akan mendiskusikan sebuah pembuktian matematis yang menetapkan bahwa ketiga representasi ini pada dasarnya setara, serta fakta bahwa mereka
semua secara benar mengkarakterisasi definisi dari apa itu channel. Ini adalah pembuktian matematis yang sangat keren menurut saya, dan semoga akan menambah
kejelasan pada berbagai presentasi ini, bagaimana mereka berhubungan, dan bagaimana cara kerjanya secara umum. Kita akan mulai dengan dasar-dasarnya dan
menjawab pertanyaan: apa itu channel? Seperti yang sudah saya sarankan di awal pelajaran, channel mendeskripsikan perubahan —
khususnya perubahan diskrit dalam sistem yang menyimpan informasi kuantum. Di sini, ketika kita merujuk pada perubahan waktu diskrit,
kita hanya memikirkan perubahan yang terjadi antara dua momen yang berbeda dalam waktu, sebagai lawan dari sebuah
proses kontinu, misalnya, yang masuk akal untuk dipikirkan dalam periode waktu yang sangat kecil. Channel mencakup operasi yang berguna seperti
operasi unitary yang dilakukan oleh quantum gate dan circuit, serta perubahan karena noise, misalnya. Namun
untuk keperluan pelajaran ini, kita sebagian besar akan berpikir tentang channel dalam istilah matematis yang abstrak dan tidak akan ada kebutuhan khusus
untuk membedakan antara apa yang berguna dan apa yang tidak. Nama-nama umum untuk channel termasuk huruf Yunani kapital fi,
psi, dan delta, dan kita akan menggunakan huruf-huruf berbeda untuk merujuk pada beberapa channel spesifik. Dalam situasi sederhana di mana
kita punya sebuah sistem yang berada dalam keadaan yang dideskripsikan oleh suatu density matrix rho dan kita menerapkan sebuah channel fi pada sistem itu,
hasilnya adalah sistem yang keadaannya dideskripsikan oleh density matrix fi dari rho. Jadi kita membayangkan sebuah
channel fi tertentu sebagai sebuah fungsi yang bisa diterapkan pada density matrix dari ukuran tertentu, atau dengan kata lain
density matrix dari sistem tertentu di mana kita menerapkan channel ini. Ada beberapa persyaratan yang harus dipenuhi oleh channel agar
dianggap sebagai channel yang valid. Pertama, channel adalah pemetaan linear. Ini sepenuhnya analog dengan situasi yang kita miliki dalam
formulasi yang disederhanakan dari informasi kuantum, di mana operasi pada vektor keadaan kuantum selalu linear, sama seperti
dalam formulasi standar informasi klasik di mana operasi probabilistik adalah linear. Kamu bisa mempertanyakan persyaratan dasar
linearitas ini kalau mau, tapi kalau kita ingin sebuah teori yang konsisten dengan teori probabilitas
dan pilihan untuk merepresentasikan keadaan kuantum dengan density matrix, kita tidak punya pilihan dan hanya harus menerima bahwa channel itu linear.
Persyaratan kedua adalah bahwa channel mengubah density matrix menjadi density matrix. Itu sangat masuk akal karena kalau kita sudah memilih untuk merepresentasikan
keadaan sistem dengan density matrix dan kita menerapkan sebuah channel pada sistem yang berada dalam suatu keadaan, maka hasilnya harus berupa keadaan yang valid dan karenanya
direpresentasikan oleh sebuah density matrix. Ada poin yang sangat penting yang perlu ditambahkan di sini, yaitu persyaratan ini
harus benar tidak hanya kalau kita menerapkan channel pada sistem yang terisolasi yang keadaannya dideskripsikan oleh sebuah density matrix,
tapi juga kalau kita punya sebuah sistem gabungan yang keadaannya dideskripsikan oleh suatu density matrix dan kita menerapkan channel hanya
pada sebagian dari sistem itu. Jadi itulah persyaratan yang kita tempatkan pada channel dan kita bisa melihat bahwa mereka sangat
analog dengan persyaratan yang kita miliki untuk operasi dalam formulasi yang disederhanakan dari informasi kuantum maupun formulasi standar
dari informasi klasik. Dalam formulasi yang disederhanakan dari informasi kuantum, operasi direpresentasikan oleh matriks unitary karena mereka
berkoresponden secara tepat dengan pemetaan linear yang selalu mengubah vektor keadaan kuantum menjadi vektor keadaan kuantum untuk suatu
sistem tertentu. Demikian juga, operasi probabilistik direpresentasikan oleh matriks stokastik karena itu adalah yang
selalu mengubah vektor probabilitas menjadi vektor probabilitas. Di sini kita bekerja dengan density matrix dan ada
persyaratan tambahan mengenai sistem gabungan yang ternyata tidak diperlukan untuk vektor keadaan kuantum
atau vektor probabilitas, tapi persyaratan lainnya tetap analog dan dalam beberapa hal dipaksakan kepada kita oleh pilihan
untuk merepresentasikan keadaan kuantum dengan density matrix. Berikut beberapa detail lebih lanjut tentang channel, termasuk sebuah konvensi
tentang bagaimana kita akan berpikir tentang sistem input dan output dari sebuah channel sepanjang pelajaran ini, serta beberapa detail lebih lanjut
tentang persyaratan bahwa channel selalu mengubah density matrix menjadi density matrix. Pertama, setiap channel
diasumsikan memiliki sistem input dan sistem output. Kita bisa menamai sistem-sistem ini sesuka kita, tapi sepanjang
pelajaran ini saya akan menggunakan nama X untuk merujuk pada sistem input dan nama Y untuk merujuk pada sistem output. Secara konseptual, channel
mengubah sistem input menjadi sistem output, sehingga sistem input dan output tidak pernah ada secara bersamaan. Kita
mulai dengan X, channel diterapkan atau dilakukan, dan hasilnya adalah X telah diubah menjadi Y yang keadaannya
ditentukan oleh pemetaan linear yang terkait dengan channel tersebut. Sistem input dan output untuk sebuah channel tidak harus sama, dan khususnya
mereka tidak harus memiliki jumlah keadaan klasik yang sama. Namun bisa saja sistem input dan output sebenarnya adalah sistem yang sama, atau dengan kata lain
WEBVTT
X sama dengan Y, di mana kita hanya membayangkan bahwa fi sedang mengubah keadaan sistem, dan ini memang
sering menjadi situasi yang kita minati. Tapi kemungkinan ini konsisten dengan poin pertama dalam artian kita tidak pernah memiliki
sistem input dan output yang ada sebagai dua sistem terpisah pada saat yang bersamaan. Dan dalam kasus apapun, akan lebih mudah
untuk keperluan pelajaran ini menggunakan huruf-huruf berbeda, yaitu X dan Y, untuk merujuk pada sistem input dan output
hanya untuk membantu kita tetap jelas. Sekarang mari kita masuk sedikit lebih dalam tentang persyaratan bahwa channel selalu mengubah density
matrix menjadi density matrix. Misalkan kita memperkenalkan sistem baru Z ke dalam gambaran ini. Mari
beri nama gamma pada himpunan keadaan klasik dari sistem baru ini. Bayangkan sekarang kita membentuk sistem gabungan baru ZX
yang terdiri dari sistem baru bersama sistem input X dari channel fi, dan misalkan sistem gabungan ini
berada dalam keadaan yang dideskripsikan oleh sebuah density matrix rho. Ini bisa berupa keadaan kuantum yang sembarang dari pasangan ini, tapi keadaan apapun itu
selalu memungkinkan untuk mengekspresikan density matrix rho dalam bentuk yang ditampilkan di layar, di mana A dan B keduanya
mencakup himpunan keadaan klasik gamma dan setiap rho AB adalah suatu matriks yang baris dan kolomnya berkoresponden dengan apapun
himpunan keadaan klasik X itu. Kita tidak perlu memberi nama pada himpunan keadaan klasik itu saat ini. Untuk memperjelas, setiap rho AB tidak harus merupakan sebuah
density matrix dengan sendirinya, tapi matriks rho secara keseluruhan pasti merupakan sebuah density matrix. Ketika kita menerapkan channel fi pada
sistem X, ia diubah menjadi Y dan kita mendapat pasangan ZY. Cara kita menentukan
keadaan pasangan ini setelah menerapkan fi hanya pada X adalah dengan mengevaluasi pemetaan linear fi pada setiap matriks rho a.
Cara lain untuk mengatakan ini adalah kita mengambil hasil kali tensor dari pemetaan fi dengan pemetaan identitas pada matriks persegi yang memiliki baris dan kolom
berkoresponden dengan gamma, dan itu pada gilirannya berkoresponden dengan tidak melakukan apa-apa pada sistem baru Z ini. Tapi ini adalah deskripsi yang setara
dan tidak mengharuskan kita masuk ke detail apapun tentang hasil kali tensor dari pemetaan seperti ini. Mereka
bekerja dengan cara yang cukup mudah yang analog dengan cara kerjanya untuk vektor dan matriks. Satu cara untuk memikirkan ini secara visual adalah
dalam hal matriks blok, dan kalau kita membuat asumsi yang menyederhanakan bahwa himpunan keadaan klasik gamma terdiri dari
bilangan bulat antara 0 dan N minus satu untuk suatu bilangan bulat positif M, maka menjadi mudah untuk menuliskan semua ini sebagaimana
ditunjukkan tepat di sini. Dan sekarang untuk mengulang persyaratan yang kita tempatkan pada fi agar menjadi channel yang valid, kita harus selalu mendapatkan sebuah density
matrix dari proses ini, dan ini harus benar terlepas dari pilihan apa yang kita buat untuk sistem Z maupun
pilihan yang kita buat untuk rho, asalkan itu adalah sebuah density matrix. Itu mungkin terlihat seperti persyaratan yang cukup ketat dan
mungkin juga terlihat sangat sulit untuk diperiksa. Tapi seperti yang akan kita lihat di akhir pelajaran, itu sebenarnya tidak seketat
atau sesulit yang dibayangkan untuk diperiksa, dan khususnya kita memiliki karakterisasi matematis yang bagus untuk kondisi ini
yang terhubung dengan berbagai representasi yang akan kita bahas sedikit lebih lanjut dalam pelajaran ini. Sekarang mari kita lihat beberapa contoh channel,
dimulai dengan seluruh kategori channel yang disebut unitary channel. Secara sederhana, ini adalah
operasi unitary seperti yang kita miliki dalam formulasi yang disederhanakan dari informasi kuantum, yang dipandang sebagai channel. Lebih tepatnya, misalkan U adalah sebuah matriks unitary
yang merepresentasikan operasi unitary pada sistem X. Jadi dalam formulasi yang disederhanakan dari informasi
kuantum, kita akan mengalikan matriks ini ke vektor keadaan kuantum yang diberikan untuk menentukan aksi yang dimiliki operasi itu pada keadaan kuantum tersebut.
Cara kerjanya untuk density matrix adalah kita mengalikan density matrix di sebelah kiri dengan U dan di sebelah kanan dengan U
dagger. Dalam istilah matematis kita menyebut operasi ini sebagai konjugasi oleh matriks U. Ini konsisten dengan psi
ket bra psi yang menjadi density matrix yang mendeskripsikan keadaan yang direpresentasikan oleh vektor keadaan kuantum psi, dan cukup
mudah untuk memeriksa bahwa khususnya kalau kita menerapkan U pada vektor keadaan kuantum ket psi maka kita mendapat U kali ket psi dan
representasi density matrix-nya diberikan oleh vektor itu dikali transpos konjugatnya, yaitu U kali ket psi kali bra psi kali U
dagger ketika kita mengevaluasi transpos konjugat dari U kali ket psi. Jadi cara channel ini didefinisikan
masuk akal untuk pure state dan ketika kita menggabungkan ini dengan linearitas kita melihat bahwa itu masuk akal untuk density matrix pada
umumnya, mengingat fakta bahwa setiap density matrix bisa diekspresikan sebagai kombinasi cembung dari pure state. Definisi
ini selalu memberi kita channel yang valid untuk pilihan operasi unitary u apapun. Khususnya, melakukan konjugasi dengan
matriks unitary seperti ini tidak mengubah trace dari sebuah matriks, dan kalau kita mengonjugasi sembarang matriks semi-definit positif
dengan matriks apapun, kita akan mendapatkan matriks semi-definit positif lainnya, dan cukup mudah untuk mendapatkan itu
langsung dari definisi matriks semi-definit positif. Jadi density matrix selalu dipetakan ke density
matrix, dan semua ini tetap benar bahkan kalau kita melakukan tensor U dengan matriks identitas ukuran berapa pun, yang setara
dengan menerapkan channel ini hanya pada sebagian dari sistem gabungan. Berikut contoh yang sangat sederhana dari unitary channel. Misalkan
kita ambil U sendiri sebagai matriks identitas. Ini jelas merupakan channel yang valid yang disebut identity channel. Melakukan
tidak ada sama sekali tentu saja merupakan operasi linear, dan kalau kita mulai dengan sebuah density matrix dan tidak melakukan apa-apa padanya, ia
akan tetap menjadi density matrix. Jadi ini adalah channel yang valid. Orang-orang menggunakan simbol-simbol berbeda untuk menunjukkan channel ini,
terkadang itu adalah simbol yang sama persis yang kita gunakan untuk matriks identitas, yang bisa sedikit membingungkan, tapi umumnya tidak. Di sini saya menggunakan
huruf ID singkatan dari identity hanya untuk menghindari kebingungan, dan notasi ini juga cukup umum. Mungkin tampak seperti
channel yang sangat membosankan, tapi dalam konteks transmisi informasi ini sebenarnya adalah channel yang sempurna di mana
penerima mendapatkan persis apa yang dikirim pengirim, yang biasanya yang paling diinginkan dalam konteks tersebut. Cara lain kita bisa
mendapatkan banyak contoh channel adalah dengan mengambil kombinasi cembung dari channel-channel atau dengan kata lain merata-ratakannya
bersama-sama. Fakta bahwa kita bisa melakukan ini adalah aspek penting dari channel. Untuk menjelaskan ini lebih detail, mari mulai dengan dua channel F0 dan F1,
katakanlah bersama dengan bilangan real P antara 0 dan 1. Untuk memperjelas, kita mengasumsikan bahwa kedua channel ini memiliki
sistem input yang sama yaitu X, serta sistem output yang sama yaitu Y. Sekarang perhatikan apa yang terjadi kalau kita memutuskan
untuk menerapkan channel pertama F0 dengan probabilitas p, dan sebaliknya dengan probabilitas 1 minus P kita menerapkan
channel kedua F1. Misalnya, mungkin kita memilih secara acak sebuah bit dengan probabilitas-probabilitas itu dan kemudian menggunakan bit acak ini
untuk menentukan channel mana yang diterapkan. Dengan melakukan ini kita secara efektif menerapkan channel baru yang mungkin kita sebut psi
yang diberikan oleh kombinasi cembung dari dua channel yang kita mulai, dan yang bisa kita ekspresikan sebagaimana ditulis
di layar. Kita selalu bisa mengambil kombinasi linear dari pemetaan linear seperti ini, dan cara sebuah kombinasi linear
WEBVTT
dari pemetaan linear didefinisikan pada input yang diberikan adalah kita hanya mengambil kombinasi linear yang sama dari output-output.
Itu mungkin terlihat agak sederhana tapi masuk akal. Output yang kita dapatkan dari skenario hipotetis ini adalah rata-rata tertimbang
dari output yang kita dapatkan dari dua channel asli. Meskipun demikian, ini adalah channel baru, dan
kalau F0 dan F1 memang channel yang valid, pasti pemetaan baru ini juga akan menjadi channel yang valid. Cara lain untuk mengatakan
itu dalam istilah matematis adalah himpunan semua channel dari sistem input tertentu ke sistem output tertentu adalah
cembung, dan itu adalah sifat matematis yang penting dari channel. Kita bisa melakukan ini secara lebih umum kalau kita punya M channel F0 sampai F m minus satu,
bersama dengan vektor probabilitas yang memberi tahu kita berapa probabilitas untuk setiap channel, maka kita mendapatkan channel baru dengan merata-ratakan channel-channel sesuai. Jadi
dalam beberapa hal ini adalah sumber channel baru yang tak terbatas. Misalnya, kelas yang disebut mixed unitary channel adalah apa
yang kita dapatkan dengan mengambil kombinasi cembung dari unitary channel. Yaitu kalau kita punya M matriks unitary u0 sampai u m minus
satu yang semuanya berukuran sama, bersama dengan vektor probabilitas, maka kalau kita mengambil rata-rata tertimbang dari channel-channel
yang berkoresponden dengan matriks unitary individual, sebagaimana ditampilkan di layar, maka kita akan mendapatkan sebuah channel, dan channel-channel
yang bisa ditulis seperti ini disebut mixed unitary channel. Tidak setiap channel adalah mixed unitary channel. Kita tidak bisa mendapatkan
setiap channel dengan cara ini, tapi mereka memang muncul cukup sering. Selanjutnya kita akan melihat beberapa
contoh spesifik dari channel. Ini semua akan menjadi contoh channel dari satu qubit ke satu qubit yang disebut
qubit channel secara singkat. Yang pertama disebut qubit reset channel, dan idenya adalah bahwa channel ini mereset sebuah qubit
ke keadaan nol. Di sini kita menggunakan huruf Yunani kapital Lambda untuk menunjukkan channel ini, dan cara kamu bisa mengingat apa yang channel ini lakukan adalah dengan
berpikir tentang Bloch sphere. Lambda kapital terlihat seperti panah yang menunjuk ke atas dan keadaan nol ada di bagian atas Bloch sphere, jadi seolah-olah
ia menunjuk ke lokasi output. Cara didefinisikannya dalam istilah matematis adalah Lambda dari rho sama dengan trace dari rho dikali ket 0 bra 0, sehingga
kalau kita mengevaluasinya pada density matrix rho manapun kita akan mendapatkan keadaan nol sebagai density matrix. Wajar untuk bertanya-tanya
mengapa kita butuh trace-nya. Bukankah kita bisa mendefinisikan Lambda dari rho menjadi ket 0 bra 0 saja tanpa trace dari rho di depan?
Dan jawabannya adalah tidak. Channel perlu berupa pemetaan linear dan itu tidak akan linear kalau kita menghapus trace dari rho. Juga ingat bahwa
terkadang kita perlu tahu bagaimana channel bekerja sebagai pemetaan linear pada input non-density matrix. Misalnya, seperti yang
kita lihat sebelumnya, kalau kita ingin tahu apa yang channel lakukan ketika kita menerapkannya pada sistem gabungan, kita perlu
mengevaluasi channel itu pada blok-blok individual dari sebuah matriks blok yang lebih besar, dan meskipun seluruh matriks blok mungkin berupa
density matrix, blok-blok individual umumnya tidak. Jadi mari kita lihat tepat apa yang channel ini lakukan ketika kita menerapkannya
hanya pada satu bagian dari sistem gabungan, dan lebih khusus lagi apa yang dilakukannya ketika kita menerapkannya pada satu dari dua qubit yang
membentuk sebuah ebit. Lebih tepatnya, misalkan A dan B adalah qubit yang sebagai pasangan berada dalam keadaan Bell fi plus, dan kita menerapkan Lambda
pada katakanlah qubit pertama A. Untuk mengetahui apa yang terjadi, pertama mari kita ekspresikan keadaan fi plus sebagai density matrix, dan
demi contoh ini mari kita gunakan notasi Dirac untuk melakukan itu. Berikut keadaan fi plus sebagai vektor keadaan kuantum, dan ini yang kita dapatkan ketika kita
mengalikan vektor ini ke transpos konjugatnya dan memperluas semuanya. Kemudian kita bisa menerapkan channel pada qubit pertama dan mengevaluasi apa yang kita dapatkan. Berikut
Lambda diterapkan pada qubit pertama, dan berikut yang kita dapatkan ketika kita mengevaluasi setiap sukunya. Trace dari ket 0 bra 0 adalah satu
dan begitu juga trace dari ket 1 bra 1. Jadi dalam dua kasus itu output dari channel adalah ket 0 bra 0 dan itu menjelaskan
dua suku dalam jawabannya. Trace dari ket 0 bra 1 di sisi lain adalah nol, begitu juga trace dari ket 1 bra 0,
sehingga kedua suku itu mengevaluasi ke nol dan karena itu tidak berkontribusi apa pun pada jawabannya. Kita sekarang bisa menyederhanakan sedikit
dan apa yang kita dapatkan adalah keadaan nol untuk qubit pertama yang adalah A, dan completely mixed state untuk
qubit kedua yang adalah B. Perhatikan khususnya bahwa kita tidak mendapatkan keadaan plus untuk B, yang tidak selalu
merupakan tebakan yang buruk kalau kita tidak tahu apa-apa tentang density matrix dan kita hanya melihat representasi vektor keadaan kuantum dari keadaan itu. Tapi
bukan begitu cara channel ini bekerja dan tidak ada channel yang bisa bekerja seperti itu. Channel Lambda disebut qubit reset channel, tapi
cara kerjanya sebenarnya lebih seperti membuang input qubit ke tempat sampah dan menggantinya dengan qubit segar dalam keadaan nol. Tapi ini sebenarnya adalah
satu-satunya qubit channel yang selalu menghasilkan keadaan nol. Berikut contoh lain dari qubit channel yang dikenal sebagai
completely dephasing channel. Yang satu ini ditunjukkan dengan Delta dan cara kerjanya adalah membiarkan entri-entri diagonal
dari sembarang matriks 2x2 tetap tidak berubah dan mengol-kan entri-entri di luar diagonal. Delta adalah huruf Yunani yang setara dengan D dalam
alfabet Latin dan itu adalah singkatan dari diagonal, jadi itu adalah salah satu cara untuk mengingat apa yang channel ini lakukan. Kita juga bisa
mengekspresikan channel ini dengan notasi Dirac seperti yang ditampilkan di layar. Untuk memperjelas, output-nya
selalu berupa matriks 2x2, jadi khususnya dua output nol merujuk pada matriks 2x2 yang semuanya nol. Kita sering melakukan
ini dan kita sudah melihat ini sebelumnya dalam seri ini. Simbol nol umumnya digunakan mungkin secara ambigu untuk berarti elemen nol
dari apapun yang sedang kita bicarakan, baik itu skalar, vektor, matriks, atau apapun. Mari lakukan hal yang sama seperti yang kita lakukan sebelumnya untuk
qubit reset channel dan lihat apa yang terjadi kalau kita menerapkan channel ini pada setengah dari sebuah ebit. Pengaturannya sama jadi saya tidak akan
membahas bagian itu, dan hasilnya adalah keadaan yang ditampilkan di layar, yang pada dasarnya adalah shared random bit. Jadi
yang channel ini lakukan pada dasarnya adalah mengubah sebuah ebit menjadi pasangan bit acak klasik yang berkorelasi sempurna.
Dan itu konsisten dengan interpretasi yang lebih umum dari channel ini. Dengan mengol-kan entri-entri di luar diagonal dari sebuah density matrix, kita secara efektif
membuang hal-hal kuantum dalam density matrix, menyisakan density matrix diagonal yang merepresentasikan
keadaan probabilistik klasik. Cara lain untuk memikirkan ini adalah bahwa channel ini merepresentasikan channel klasik tanpa noise yang sempurna yang mentransmisikan sebuah bit.
Jadi kalau kita memasukkan keadaan nol atau keadaan satu atau kombinasi cembung dari kedua keadaan itu ke channel, maka keadaan itu keluar tidak berubah. Tapi kalau kamu mencoba
memasukkan keadaan kuantum ke dalamnya seperti keadaan plus misalnya, seolah-olah channel mengukur keadaan itu dengan pengukuran basis standar dan kemudian
mentransmisikan hasil klasiknya. Satu contoh terakhir dari qubit channel adalah completely depolarizing channel. Apa
yang channel ini lakukan adalah selalu menghasilkan completely mixed state, jadi ini mirip dalam beberapa hal dengan qubit reset
channel kecuali bahwa kita mendapatkan completely mixed state yang kurang berguna dibandingkan qubit yang sudah diinisialisasi. Cara alami
untuk memikirkan channel ini adalah bahwa ia merepresentasikan bentuk ekstrem dari noise, dan sejauh qubit channel bersangkutan,
tidak ada yang bisa lebih berisik dari ini. Saya tidak punya mnemonik yang bagus untuk membagikan cara mengingat apa yang satu ini lakukan selain mengatakan bahwa Omega adalah huruf terakhir
dari alfabet Yunani dan terkadang dikaitkan dengan akhir dari segala sesuatu, dan mungkin inilah yang terjadi
WEBVTT
pada semua qubit pada akhirnya. Sejauh noise berjalan, ini cukup ekstrem. Tapi satu hal yang bisa kita lakukan adalah mempertimbangkan sebuah kombinasi cembung
dari channel ini dan identity channel dengan mungkin probabilitas kecil epsilon untuk depolarisasi lengkap.
Ini adalah bentuk noise yang kurang ekstrem di mana keadaan qubit tertentu sebagian besar akan dibiarkan saja, tetapi ada
kemungkinan kecil bahwa ia menjadi completely mixed. Secara geometris kita bisa memikirkan ini sebagai kontraksi ringan dari Bloch sphere menuju pusatnya.
Dan omong-omong kita bisa melakukan hal yang serupa dengan completely dephasing channel untuk memodelkan proses dekoherensi, misalnya, di mana sesuatu
menjadi sedikit lebih klasik melalui beberapa proses. Jadi itulah tiga contoh dasar dari qubit channel, dan kita
akan kembali ke mereka terutama sebagai sumber contoh sepanjang sisa pelajaran ini. Selanjutnya kita akan mendiskusikan representasi matematis
dari channel, dimulai dengan pertanyaan dasar. Pemetaan linear dari vektor ke vektor selalu bisa
direpresentasikan oleh matriks dengan cara yang familiar, yaitu aksi dari pemetaan linear dideskripsikan oleh perkalian matriks
vektor. Tapi channel adalah pemetaan linear dari matriks ke matriks, bukan vektor ke vektor. Jadi
secara umum bagaimana kita bisa mengekspresikan channel dalam istilah matematis? Terkadang untuk channel-channel khusus kita akan punya rumus sederhana
yang mendeskripsikannya, dan itu adalah kasusnya dalam contoh-contoh qubit channel yang sudah kita diskusikan. Tapi
itu tidak praktis secara umum karena tidak selalu ada rumus yang seindah itu. Sebagai pembanding, dalam formulasi yang disederhanakan
dari informasi kuantum kita menggunakan matriks unitary untuk merepresentasikan operasi pada vektor keadaan kuantum.
Setiap matriks unitary merepresentasikan operasi yang valid dan setiap operasi yang valid bisa diekspresikan sebagai matriks unitary. Jadi
pada dasarnya apa yang ditanyakan oleh pertanyaan ini adalah bagaimana kita melakukan ini untuk channel, dan jawaban dari pertanyaan ini adalah bahwa sebenarnya ada beberapa cara untuk merepresentasikan
channel dalam istilah matematis. Khususnya kita akan mendiskusikan tiga cara berbeda untuk merepresentasikan channel yang
dinamai berdasarkan tiga orang yang karyanya memainkan peran penting dalam pengembangannya: Stinespring, Kraus, dan Choi.
Pertama kita akan melihat bagaimana representasi-representasi yang berbeda ini bekerja, dan kemudian di bagian terakhir pelajaran kita akan melihat bagaimana ketiga representasi berhubungan dan
khususnya bagaimana kita bisa mengkonversi antara mereka. Kita juga akan melihat bahwa representasi-representasi ini secara tepat menangkap persyaratan yang kita miliki pada channel,
yaitu bahwa mereka adalah pemetaan linear dan bahwa mereka selalu mengubah density matrix menjadi density matrix bahkan ketika
mereka diterapkan hanya pada satu bagian dari sistem gabungan. Pertama adalah representasi Stinespring. Willam Forrest Stine
spring adalah seorang matematikawan yang tidak bekerja pada informasi kuantum, dan representasi Stinespring seperti yang akan saya deskripsikan
dalam beberapa hal hanyalah turunan dari karyanya tentang teori operator di tahun 1950-an. Tapi karya ini tentu saja
merupakan bagian penting dari pengembangan matematika yang menjadi dasar quantum channel. Ide di balik cara merepresentasikan channel ini adalah bahwa setiap
channel bisa diimplementasikan dengan cara tertentu yang sekarang akan saya deskripsikan. Pertama kita membentuk sistem gabungan yang terdiri dari
input ke channel yang kita implementasikan bersama dengan sistem workspace yang sudah diinisialisasi. Kemudian
operasi unitary dilakukan pada sistem gabungan tersebut, dan akhirnya apapun bagian dari sistem gabungan yang dihasilkan
berkoresponden dengan output dari channel dibiarkan saja atau dihasilkan, dan sisanya dibuang atau di-trace out. Ini berguna untuk
mengekspresikan ini dalam bentuk diagram, dan paling sederhana dimulai dengan kasus khusus di mana sistem input dan
output adalah sama. Diagram ini omong-omong seperti diagram quantum circuit kecuali bahwa kabel-kabelnya
merepresentasikan sistem sembarang dan belum tentu qubit tunggal. Jadi kita mulai dengan sistem input X yang berada dalam beberapa
keadaan rho. Kita memperkenalkan sistem workspace W yang sudah diinisialisasi, dan dalam diagram ini saya mengasumsikan bahwa nol adalah sebuah keadaan klasik
dari W dan kita mengambil ket 0 sebagai keadaan yang sudah diinisialisasi dari sistem itu. Tapi kita juga bisa memperbaiki sembarang pure state
dari W dan memandangnya sebagai keadaan yang diinisialisasi. Kita kemudian melakukan beberapa operasi unitary pada pasangan WX, dan kemudian
trace out sistem workspace dan output X. Di sini dalam diagram omong-omong saya menggunakan simbol ground dari
teknik elektro untuk menunjukkan bahwa W sedang dibuang. Itu tidak selalu konvensional dan kamu tidak akan
menemukan simbol itu di Qiskit. Di sana kamu hanya mengabaikan qubit-qubit yang tidak kamu minati. Yang penting adalah saya hanya ingin punya simbol yang membuatnya
jelas bahwa kita membuang sistem untuk keperluan diskusi ini. Secara umum kita tidak harus membutuhkan
sistem input dan output yang sama, jadi kita bisa punya misalnya sistem output Y bersama dengan sistem garbage
G yang di-trace out. Agar U menjadi unitary, ia harus berupa matriks persegi, jadi ada asumsi
di sini bahwa pasangan GY bersama-sama memiliki jumlah keadaan klasik yang sama dengan pasangan WX. Misalnya mungkin sistem-sistem ini
terdiri dari qubit dan sistem input X terdiri dari 5 qubit dan W terdiri dari 10 qubit, jadi U adalah operasi unitary
pada 15 qubit. Kemudian bisa saja Y terdiri dari hanya empat qubit yang berarti bahwa G terdiri dari 11 qubit.
Atau mungkin ini bukan qubit sama sekali — yang penting adalah WX bersama-sama dan GY bersama-sama memiliki jumlah
keadaan klasik yang sama sehingga U bisa menjadi unitary. Deskripsi dari sebuah channel seperti ini disebut representasi Stinespring dari channel tersebut. Sekarang ini
cukup mudah untuk berargumen bahwa sembarang pemetaan fi yang bisa dideskripsikan dengan cara ini sebenarnya adalah channel yang valid.
Khususnya kalau kita mulai dengan density matrix dan kemudian menambahkan sistem workspace tambahan, maka kita tentu akan
mendapat density matrix. Kita sudah mengamati bahwa menerapkan operasi unitary memberikan kita channel yang valid, dan
kalau kita punya density matrix dari sistem gabungan dan kita trace out salah satu sistemnya, maka kita akan mendapat density matrix lagi. Jadi ketika kita menyusun
langkah-langkah ini, kita dijamin bahwa itu selalu mengubah density matrix menjadi density matrix, dan itu juga linear.
Yang sama sekali tidak jelas pada titik ini adalah bahwa setiap channel memang bisa diimplementasikan dengan cara ini untuk beberapa pilihan
dari sistem workspace dan sistem garbage serta operasi unitary U tentu saja. Tapi itu benar dan kita
akan melihat alasannya di akhir pelajaran. Berikut contoh representasi Stinespring untuk completely dephasing
qubit channel. Dan untuk memperjelas sekarang kabel-kabelnya adalah qubit dan ini adalah controlled NOT biasa
yang sangat sederhana. Input qubit ada di atas dan kita memperkenalkan workspace qubit yang diinisialisasi ke keadaan nol.
Kita kemudian melakukan operasi controlled NOT di mana input qubit adalah kontrol dan workspace qubit adalah
target, dan kemudian workspace qubit di-trace out. Secara intuitif, ini masuk akal
bahwa ini harus mengimplementasikan completely dephasing channel karena controlled NOT gate seperti melakukan pengukuran basis standar pada qubit
atas dengan menyalin keadaan klasiknya ke qubit bawah dan kemudian hasilnya dibuang.
Tapi kita juga bisa melakukan kalkulasi dan tentu saja ide yang bagus untuk melakukan itu karena kita benar-benar
WEBVTT
tidak boleh terlalu banyak mempercayai intuisi kita. Kita bisa mulai dengan menuliskan representasi density matrix dari
dua qubit setelah workspace qubit diperkenalkan, dan perhatikan bahwa kita menggunakan konvensi pengurutan qubit seperti
biasa di mana qubit bawah adalah yang kiri dan qubit atas ada di kanan. Kita bisa mengekspresikan density matrix ini
secara eksplisit sebagai matriks 4x4 aktual seperti yang ditampilkan di layar, dan kemudian kita menghitung efek
yang dimiliki controlled NOT gate pada density matrix ini. Jadi kita mengonjugasi dengan matriks unitary yang terkait dengan
gate ini, sekali lagi mengingat konvensi pengurutan qubit, sehingga ini adalah matriks unitary yang benar.
Dan hasilnya ditampilkan di sini. Faktanya, controlled NOT gate
mempermutas entri-entri dari matriks asli kita sedikit, sehingga sekarang entri-entri yang mungkin tidak nol ada di
empat sudut. Tinggal menghitung partial trace dan kita bisa melakukan itu langsung dari matriks, tapi
alternatifnya adalah mengkonversi ke notasi Dirac seperti yang ditampilkan di layar, dan kemudian cukup mudah untuk mengevaluasi
apa yang terjadi ketika kita trace out qubit di sebelah kiri dalam setiap suku, dan hasilnya adalah hanya
suku-suku yang berkoresponden dengan entri diagonal dari rho yang bertahan dan kita sudah melakukan dephasing pada qubit seperti
yang diharapkan. Seperti biasa, periksa ini sendiri dengan kecepatan kamu sendiri kalau kamu mau. Ini adalah contoh yang baik
untuk berlatih bekerja dengan density matrix dan dengan partial
trace. Itu bukan satu-satunya cara untuk mengimplementasikan completely dephasing channel. Berikut representasi Stinespring alternatif untuk channel
ini. Saya tidak akan membahas kalkulasi secara detail dalam video ini, tapi saya akan menampilkannya sebentar kalau kamu mau menjeda video dan melihat
lebih dekat. Cara kerjanya mirip dengan yang pertama tapi detailnya
berbeda. Kali ini kita mulai dengan Hadamard gate pada workspace qubit yang menempatkannya ke dalam keadaan plus, dan kalau
kita memperluas hasil kali tensor kita mendapatkan matriks yang ditampilkan di layar. Untuk menerapkan control Z gate kita
mengonjugasi dengan matriks unitary yang terkait dan hasilnya dari melakukan itu adalah menyuntikkan beberapa tanda minus ke dalam
matriks. Khususnya baris terakhir dan kolom terakhir keduanya dikalikan dengan negatif 1.
Dan kali ini akan cukup berantakan untuk mengkonversi ke notasi Dirac, jadi kita akan menghitung partial trace
secara langsung. Ketika kita trace out qubit pertama dari dua qubit, yang kita dapatkan adalah jumlah dari dua blok diagonal 2x2,
dan hasilnya lagi-lagi adalah kita sudah melakukan dephasing pada qubit. Itu cepat, dan kalau kamu belum
terbiasa dengan jenis kalkulasi ini, ambil waktu kamu dan lakukan perlahan. Kecepatan tidak penting
di sini. Untuk menyelesaikan contoh ini, izinkan saya menyebutkan bahwa ada ide yang cukup sederhana di balik implementasi ini yang
cukup bagus diungkapkan oleh langkah terakhir dari kalkulasi yang baru saja kita lewati. Cara yang lebih ringkas untuk mengatakan ini
adalah bahwa kalau kita merata-ratakan density matrix qubit tertentu dengan density matrix itu yang dikonjugasi oleh matriks Pauli Z, maka
itu sama dengan dephasing. Jadi completely dephasing channel ternyata adalah mixed unitary
channel di mana kita baik tidak melakukan apa-apa, atau dengan kata lain melakukan operasi identitas, atau melakukan Z gate, masing-masing
dengan probabilitas 1/2. Bagus untuk diketahui. Jadi singkatnya kita punya dua representasi Stinespring yang berbeda
dari completely dephasing channel, dan itu memberi tahu kita sesuatu yang penting, yaitu bahwa representasi Stinespring tidaklah
unik, dan sebenarnya ada jumlah tak terbatas dari mereka untuk channel manapun. Selanjutnya kita mendiskusikan representasi Kraus
dari channel, yang memberi kita cara formulaik yang nyaman untuk mengekspresikan channel melalui perkalian matriks
dan penjumlahan. Representasi Kraus dinamai berdasarkan Karl Kraus yang adalah seorang fisikawan yang antara lain
mengerjakan banyak detail matematis dasar dari channel dan formulasi umum dari informasi kuantum secara lebih luas. Secara umum sebuah
representasi Kraus adalah ekspresi dari sebuah channel yang mengambil bentuk yang ditampilkan di sini di layar. Khususnya kita punya sebuah
koleksi matriks yang di sini dinamai A z sampai A n minus satu untuk beberapa bilangan bulat positif n, dan mereka menentukan
aksi dari channel pada input rho manapun sesuai dengan rumusnya. Singkatnya kita mengonjugasi rho dengan setiap matriks ini,
yang sering disebut sebagai Kraus matrix dalam konteks ini, dan kemudian kita menjumlahkan hasilnya dan itu memberi kita output. Semua matriks ini harus memiliki
dimensi yang sama, dan secara khusus kolom-kolomnya harus berkoresponden dengan keadaan klasik dari sistem input, dan
baris-barisnya harus berkoresponden dengan keadaan klasik dari sistem output. Kalau itu kasusnya, maka ketika kita mengambil hasil kali AK kali rho kali AK dagger untuk
pilihan K manapun kita mendapatkan matriks persegi yang baris dan kolomnya berkoresponden dengan keadaan klasik dari sistem output,
sehingga masuk akal bahwa ekspresi itu menghasilkan density matrix dari sistem output. Sekarang bukan masalahnya
bahwa untuk pilihan sembarang dari Kraus matrix ini kita mendapatkan channel yang valid. Namun ada kondisi yang cukup sederhana
pada matriks yang menjamin bahwa kita akan mendapatkan channel yang valid, dan kondisi itu adalah rumus yang ditampilkan tepat di sini.
Secara khusus, kalau kita menjumlahkan hasil kali AK dagger kali AK untuk semua nilai K,
maka kita harus mendapatkan matriks identitas, dan itu akan menjadi matriks identitas yang baris dan kolomnya berkoresponden dengan
keadaan klasik dari sistem input. Jadi kondisi itu harus dipenuhi agar pemetaan yang didefinisikan oleh
persamaan pertama menjadi channel yang valid, dan ternyata setiap channel memang punya representasi yang mengambil
bentuk ini asalkan kita mengambil n yang cukup besar. Berikut beberapa contoh dari representasi Kraus
dimulai dengan qubit reset channel. Kita bisa mendapatkan representasi Kraus untuk channel ini dengan menggunakan
dua Kraus matrix: ket 0 bra 0 dan ket 0 bra 1. Jadi n sama dengan dua dalam contoh ini.
Kita bisa memasukkan pilihan-pilihan ini ke dalam rumus umum dan kita punya hanya dua suku sehingga mudah untuk menulis penjumlahannya,
dan kalau kita menyederhanakan dan mengenali bahwa ekspresi dalam tanda kurung adalah trace dari rho maka kita melihat bahwa kita mendapatkan
qubit reset channel. Kita juga bisa memeriksa bahwa kondisi yang diperlukan pada matriks-matriks ini terpenuhi, dan itu hanya masalah memasukkan Kraus
matrix ke dalam persamaan dan mengevaluasi, dan kita mendapatkan matriks identitas seperti yang diperlukan. Untuk contoh lain, mari kita lihat lagi
completely dephasing channel. Mengambil matriks ket 0 bra 0 dan ket 1 bra 1 berhasil, dan itu bisa diperiksa dengan
memperluas penjumlahan dan melihat cukup langsung bahwa kita mendapatkan apa yang kita butuhkan, dan lagi kondisi yang diperlukan terpenuhi. Sebuah
alternatifnya adalah mengambil A nol menjadi matriks identitas dibagi akar kuadrat dari 2 dan A1 menjadi
Sigma Z dibagi akar kuadrat dari 2, dan kalau kita mengevaluasi kita melihat bahwa lagi kita mendapatkan completely dephasing channel berdasarkan pengamatan
WEBVTT
yang kita buat tentang channel ini sedikit lebih awal dalam pelajaran ini, dan sekali lagi kondisi yang diperlukan cukup mudah
untuk diperiksa sebagai latihan yang bisa dikerjakan kalau kamu merasa itu membantu. Pertimbangkan completely depolarizing
channel yang menghasilkan completely mixed state untuk setiap input density matrix. Untuk yang satu ini, empat Kraus matrix
diperlukan. Tidak mungkin untuk membuat representasi Kraus di mana n adalah tiga atau kurang. Berikut satu pilihan yang berhasil, dan
berikut pilihan lainnya. Jadi latihannya adalah memverifikasi bahwa pilihan-pilihan ini berhasil serta memeriksa bahwa kondisi yang diperlukan
terpenuhi. Ini layak untuk dicatat bahwa alternatif kedua pada dasarnya mengatakan bahwa mungkin untuk sepenuhnya mendepolarisasi sebuah qubit, atau dengan kata lain
sepenuhnya mengacaknya, dengan memilih secara acak salah satu dari empat matriks Pauli termasuk identitas dan menerapkan
operasi unitary yang berkoresponden ke qubit. Jadi completely depolarizing channel adalah contoh lain dari mixed
unitary channel. Yang terakhir dari tiga representasi channel yang akan kita bahas adalah representasi Choi. Manduin Choi
adalah seorang matematikawan yang bekerja pada teori matriks dan topik-topik lainnya, dan representasi Choi dinamai untuk menghormatinya
berdasarkan makalah yang sangat elegan yang diterbitkannya pada tahun 1975 yang dalam beberapa hal mengikat semua hal ini bersama-sama. Representasi Choi
dari sebuah channel fi adalah sebuah matriks tunggal yang secara konvensional ditunjukkan dengan J fi, dan secara khusus kalau
sistem input memiliki n keadaan klasik dan sistem output memiliki m keadaan klasik, maka representasi Choi dari fi akan berupa
matriks persegi n kali m kali n kali m. Sebelum saya memberi tahu kamu persis bagaimana matriks didefinisikan, saya ingin menyebutkan beberapa
sifat utamanya yang memotivasi representasinya dengan cara yang mungkin tidak dilakukan oleh definisi aktual itu sendiri, setidaknya di
permukaan. Pertama, tidak seperti representasi Stinespring dan representasi Kraus, representasi Choi
adalah representasi yang disebut faithful, yang berarti setiap channel hanya punya satu representasi Choi, dan itu cukup penting
karena itu mengatakan bahwa dua channel adalah sama jika dan hanya jika representasi Choi mereka sama. Jadi kalau kamu
memiliki dua deskripsi yang berbeda dari channel seperti dua representasi Stinespring yang berbeda atau dua representasi Kraus yang berbeda, atau mungkin satu dari
masing-masing, dan kamu ingin tahu apakah mereka sebenarnya adalah channel yang sama, kamu hanya perlu menghitung representasi Choi dan
memeriksa apakah keduanya sama atau tidak. Sifat kedua adalah bahwa ada kondisi-kondisi yang mudah diperiksa pada representasi Choi yang benar jika dan hanya
jika kita punya channel yang valid. Sifat itu tidak terlalu istimewa — kita bisa mengatakan hal yang sama tentang dua representasi lainnya — tapi tetap merupakan sifat yang bagus
untuk dimiliki dan kita akan mendiskusikannya lebih detail segera. Satu hal lagi yang perlu dicatat tentang representasi Choi adalah bahwa meskipun kita
merepresentasikan sebuah channel dengan sebuah matriks, matriks ini tidak secara langsung merepresentasikan channel sebagai pemetaan linear. Faktanya
lebih alami untuk mengasosiasikan representasi Choi dengan density matrix yang merepresentasikan keadaan tertentu
daripada berpikir tentang representasi Choi sebagai mendeskripsikan pemetaan linear. Namun memang mungkin untuk memulihkan aksi channel dari
representasi Choi-nya menggunakan rumus yang cukup sederhana, tapi tidak sesederhana perkalian matriks biasa.
Itu cukup untuk pembukaannya. Mari kita ke definisi sebenarnya. Misalkan kita punya sebuah channel fi dari sistem X ke sistem Y
dan asumsikan bahwa himpunan keadaan klasik dari sistem input X adalah Sigma. Kita tidak perlu merujuk pada himpunan keadaan klasik dari sistem output, jadi
untuk definisi tidak perlu menamainya. Representasi Choi dari fi kemudian didefinisikan oleh ekspresi
yang ditampilkan di sini di layar. Kita punya penjumlahan yang mencakup semua keadaan klasik A dan B untuk sistem input dan kita
menjumlahkan ket a bra B di-tensor dengan channel fi yang diterapkan pada ket a bra B. Jadi
representasi ini didefinisikan oleh sebuah rumus dan ada beberapa cara berbeda yang bisa kita pikirkan tentang rumus ini. Sebelum saya mendiskusikannya, izinkan saya
menyebutkan bahwa terkadang representasi Choi didefinisikan dengan cara yang sedikit berbeda di mana urutan dari dua faktor tensor dibalik, yang berarti
bahwa fi dari ket a bra muncul sebagai faktor tensor pertama daripada yang kedua. Tapi dua cara berbeda untuk melakukannya adalah
setara dengan simetri sederhana ini. Tapi artinya adalah ketika kamu menggunakan representasi ini, ide yang bagus adalah
untuk memperjelas pengurutan mana yang kamu gunakan. Pengurutan ini adalah cara yang dilakukan di Qiskit dan juga lebih baik untuk
mendeskripsikan representasi secara visual dalam hal matriks blok, jadi ini yang akan kita gunakan. Untuk lebih spesifik tentang deskripsi matriks blok,
kalau kita mengasumsikan bahwa himpunan keadaan klasik Sigma terdiri dari bilangan bulat dari nol sampai n minus satu
untuk beberapa bilangan bulat positif n, maka kita bisa menulis J fi sebagai matriks blok seperti yang ditampilkan tepat di sini di
layar. Dengan kata lain, representasi Choi dari fi adalah matriks yang kita dapatkan dengan mengevaluasi fi pada setiap
matriks input yang memiliki tepat satu entri yang sama dengan satu dengan semua entri lainnya nol, dan kemudian mengaturnya
menjadi sebuah matriks dengan cara yang cukup natural. Mungkin tidak jelas a priori mengapa kita ingin membentuk matriks seperti ini, tapi ternyata
sangat berguna. Satu hal yang perlu dicatat adalah bahwa himpunan yang mengandung matriks ket a bra b saat
a dan b keduanya mencakup semua bilangan bulat dari 0 sampai n minus satu membentuk basis untuk ruang semua matriks n kali n. Jadi kalau
kamu punya matriks ini, kamu tentu bisa menentukan apa yang fi lakukan pada matriks n kali n yang sembarang berdasarkan linearitas,
khususnya dengan mengambil kombinasi linear yang tepat dari blok-bloknya. Jadi matriks J fi memang secara unik
menentukan fi sebagai pemetaan linear. Cara lain untuk berpikir tentang representasi Choi dari sebuah channel adalah bahwa
ia merepresentasikan sebuah keadaan sebagai density matrix ketika dinormalisasi, khususnya dengan membaginya dengan jumlah
keadaan klasik dari sistem input yang akan saya terus sebut dengan huruf kecil n. Ini selalu akan memberi kita
density matrix yang sering disebut sebagai Choi state dari channel. Berikut cara kerjanya secara lebih detail.
Bayangkan pertama kita punya dua salinan identik dari sistem input dan kita mempertimbangkan vektor keadaan kuantum psi
yang ditampilkan di layar, yang merepresentasikan keadaan yang disebut maximally entangled dari pasangan sistem identik ini. Untuk
instance kalau Sigma adalah alfabet biner maka ini adalah keadaan fi plus, tapi kita bisa memikirkan keadaan yang didefinisikan secara analog untuk
pilihan Sigma manapun, dan yang kita dapatkan adalah keadaan yang sangat terjalin dan bahkan terentang semaksimal yang bisa didapat
dengan pilihan sistem ini. Untuk mendapatkan representasi density matrix dari keadaan tersebut kita mengalikan vektor keadaan ke transpos konjugatnya seperti biasa, dan
ini tampilannya. Dan akhirnya kalau kita berpikir tentang representasi Choi dari channel yang dibagi n, maka kita melihat bahwa itu adalah keadaan
yang akan kita dapatkan kalau kita menerapkan channel fi ke sistem kedua. Dalam bentuk diagram, berikut
tampilannya. Kita punya dua salinan dari sistem X dalam keadaan maximally entangled psi. Channel fi
diterapkan ke sistem kedua yang adalah yang di atas dalam diagram, dan keadaan yang dihasilkan adalah Choi state dari fi. Tentu saja kita biasanya tidak
memberi nama yang sama untuk dua sistem yang berbeda seperti ini — umumnya tidak membantu untuk memberi nama yang sama pada dua hal yang berbeda — tapi memang masuk akal
WEBVTT
dalam kasus ini hanya untuk membuat koneksi dengan representasi Choi. Ada beberapa implikasi yang bisa langsung kita ambil dari cara
melihat representasi Choi ini. Satu adalah bahwa karena Choi state adalah density matrix (dengan asumsi bahwa fi adalah
channel yang valid), kita menyimpulkan bahwa representasi Choi dari fi harus semi-definit positif. Ingat bahwa itu adalah
persyaratan yang kita tempatkan pada channel bahwa mereka selalu mengubah density matrix menjadi density matrix, dan ini
hanyalah satu kasus khusus dari ini. Implikasi kedua adalah bahwa kalau kita mengambil Choi state untuk channel fi manapun dan
kemudian membuang sistem output Y, maka kita pasti mendapat completely mixed state pada sistem input X. Itu karena
menerapkan channel ke sebuah sistem dan kemudian membuang sistem yang dihasilkan ke tempat sampah setara dengan hanya membuang sistem asli ke
tempat sampah, dan kalau kita melakukan itu dengan maximally entangled state kita, density matrix yang tersisa adalah
matriks identitas dibagi n, atau dengan kata lain completely mixed state untuk sistem X. Ide dalam istilah
matematis yang lebih formal adalah bahwa menyusun channel manapun dengan trace pada sistem output harus sama dengan trace pada
sistem input, dan itu karena channel harus mempertahankan trace berdasarkan fakta bahwa mereka adalah pemetaan linear yang
selalu mengubah density matrix menjadi density matrix. Setelah kita punya persamaan ini, kita bisa menghilangkan penyebut n
dari kedua sisi untuk mendapatkan kondisi yang sedikit lebih bersih. Dalam kata-kata, melakukan partial trace pada sistem output
dari representasi Choi dari sebuah channel harus memberi kita matriks identitas pada sistem input. Jadi singkatnya, representasi Choi
dari channel selalu semi-definit positif, dan kalau kita trace out sistem output, kita pasti
mendapat matriks identitas pada sistem input. Ternyata ini bukan hanya kondisi yang diperlukan tapi juga
kondisi yang cukup, yang berarti bahwa kalau fi adalah pemetaan linear sembarang dan kedua kondisi ini kebetulan benar,
maka fi pasti merupakan channel yang valid, dan kita akan melihat alasannya di akhir pelajaran.
Mari kita lihat beberapa contoh dimulai dengan completely dephasing channel. Untuk menghitung representasi Choi tinggal
mengevaluasi rumusnya. Completely dephasing channel membiarkan ket a bra b tidak berubah ketika a sama dengan b dan sebaliknya outputnya
adalah nol. Jadi suku-suku dalam penjumlahan yang bertahan adalah yang di mana a sama dengan b, dan hasilnya diekspresikan di
layar menggunakan notasi Dirac. Kita juga bisa melihatnya sebagai matriks blok. Delta membiarkan entri diagonal tidak berubah dan mengol-kan entri
di luar diagonal, sehingga kita mendapat matriks yang memiliki satu di sudut kiri atas dan kanan bawah dengan semua
entri lainnya nol, dan itu konsisten dengan ekspresi pertama. Untuk contoh lain, mari pertimbangkan completely depolarizing channel. Lagi kita
bisa mulai dengan menuliskan rumusnya dan seperti pada contoh sebelumnya kita tidak mendapatkan kontribusi pada penjumlahan
ketika a tidak sama dengan b, dan kali ini ketika a sama dengan b kita mendapatkan completely mixed state, dan kita bisa menyederhanakan itu menjadi
1/2 kali matriks identitas 2x2 di-tensor dengan dirinya sendiri yang adalah 1/2 kali matriks identitas 4x4.
Kita juga bisa memikirkannya dalam hal matriks blok dan secara alami kita mendapatkan hasil yang sama. Dan sebagai
contoh terakhir mari pertimbangkan identity channel untuk qubit tunggal. Ini yang mudah. Berikut rumusnya, dan tentu saja
identity channel tidak melakukan apa-apa sama sekali, dan kita bisa memikirkan hasilnya sebagai dua kali density matrix yang terkait dengan keadaan fi plus, dan itu
konsisten dengan apa yang kita harapkan dengan berpikir tentang Choi state dari channel ini. Dan berikut sebagai matriks blok. Perhatikan khususnya bahwa representasi Choi
dari identity channel bukanlah matriks identitas; itu adalah matriks ini. Kita sekarang sudah melihat tiga cara berbeda
untuk merepresentasikan channel dalam istilah matematis, yaitu representasi Stinespring, representasi Kraus, dan representasi Choi.
Kita juga punya definisi dari sebuah channel, yaitu bahwa channel adalah pemetaan linear yang selalu
mengubah density matrix menjadi density matrix bahkan ketika channel diterapkan hanya pada sebagian dari sistem gabungan. Pertanyaan yang sangat natural dan sangat penting
untuk ditanyakan pada titik ini adalah bagaimana kita tahu semua hal ini setara? Misalnya, bagaimana kita tahu bahwa setiap
pemetaan yang dideskripsikan oleh salah satu dari representasi-representasi ini sebenarnya merupakan channel yang valid? Dan bagaimana kita tahu bahwa kita tidak meninggalkan channel manapun?
Sisa pelajaran mendeskripsikan bagaimana semua ini bisa dipikirkan secara matematis. Kalau kamu mau menerima kesetaraan hal-hal ini dan kamu tidak tertarik bagaimana hal itu bisa
dipikirkan, kamu bebas untuk melewati sisa video. Tapi saya pribadi berpikir argumennya cukup
keren dan merupakan contoh yang bagus dari gaya pembuktian matematis tertentu yang muncul dari waktu ke waktu dalam teori informasi kuantum. Saya tidak akan
membahas semua detailnya. Beberapa akan saya tinggalkan untuk kamu atau kamu bisa menemukannya di konten tertulis untuk pelajaran ini di mana semuanya ditulis
secara detail. Tapi saya berharap dapat menyajikan gambaran yang cukup jelas tentang bagaimana semuanya bekerja. Yang ingin kita lakukan adalah membuktikan
kesetaraan dari sekumpulan pernyataan, dan cara kita melakukan ini adalah dengan menyiapkan siklus implikasi. Khususnya kita akan mulai
dengan definisi dari sebuah channel, yang berarti pemetaan linear yang selalu mengubah density matrix menjadi density matrix.
Dari definisi ini kita bisa menyimpulkan bahwa representasi Choi dari channel ini harus memenuhi dua kondisi yang sudah kita
identifikasi, dan sebenarnya kita sudah melakukan ini. Ini dibahas dalam konteks Choi state dari sebuah channel. Kita kemudian melupakan semua
tentang definisi dan kita bekerja dari representasi Choi, dan diberikan dua kondisi kita pada representasi Choi, kita menyimpulkan bahwa pasti ada
representasi Kraus dari pemetaan fi. Kita kemudian melakukan hal yang analog — kita melupakan tentang representasi Choi dan kita bekerja
dari representasi Kraus yang sembarang, dan dari itu kita bisa menyimpulkan bahwa pasti ada representasi Stinespring untuk pemetaan fi. Dan omong-omong, argumen-argumen ini
bersifat mekanis dalam beberapa hal, yang memungkinkan kita untuk sebenarnya melakukan konversi sesuai dengan panah untuk channel-channel tertentu kalau kita mau
melakukan itu. Implikasi terakhir adalah menyimpulkan bahwa kalau kita punya representasi Stinespring untuk pemetaan fi, maka
pemetaan itu pasti merupakan channel yang valid, dan lagi kita sudah melakukan itu, kali ini dalam konteks representasi Stinespring.
Secara keseluruhan, keempat implikasi ini mengungkapkan bahwa keempat hal ini semua setara karena kamu bisa mulai dari salah satu dari mereka dan
mengikuti implikasi secara transitif untuk sampai ke salah satu dari yang lain. Kita akan mulai dengan implikasi pertama,
yaitu kalau kita punya channel fi yang berarti pemetaan linear yang selalu mengubah density matrix menjadi density matrix, maka ia punya representasi Choi
yang memenuhi dua kondisi yang kita identifikasi sebelumnya, yaitu bahwa ia semi-definit positif
dan kalau kita trace out sistem output kita mendapat identitas pada sistem input. Dan seperti yang saya sebutkan sebentar lalu kita
sudah membahas implikasi ini dalam konteks Choi state. Khususnya ketika kita membagi representasi Choi dari sebuah channel dengan n, jumlah
keadaan klasik dari sistem input, kita mendapatkan density matrix. Dan selain itu, keadaan yang direduksi dari sistem input
X untuk keadaan itu adalah completely mixed state, atau dengan kata lain matriks identitas dibagi n. Menghilangkan penyebut memberi kita
dua kondisi kita. Jadi implikasi ini cukup cepat dan mudah karena kita sudah membahasnya.
WEBVTT
Sekarang mari kita lihat implikasi kedua. Kali ini kita mulai dengan representasi Choi dari sebuah pemetaan yang
kita asumsikan memenuhi dua persyaratan, dan tujuan kita adalah untuk membuat representasi Kraus untuk pemetaan ini yang
memenuhi persyaratan yang kita bicarakan sebelumnya. Implikasi ini cukup mekanis dalam artian tertentu. Kita akan membutuhkan
sedikit aljabar linear dan itu sebagian besar akan bermuara pada memanipulasi matriks dan vektor dengan cara yang cukup cerdas.
Dimulai dengan asumsi bahwa representasi Choi adalah semi-definit positif, yang merupakan yang pertama dari dua persyaratan yang kita asumsikan
berlaku. Gagasan matriks semi-definit positif sangat penting dalam informasi kuantum dan tidak hanya dalam konteks density
matrix. Ini sangat kritis di sini — kita tidak akan bisa membuat ini bekerja tanpanya. Khususnya, asumsi
bahwa J fi adalah semi-definit positif memungkinkan kita untuk mengekspresikannya dalam bentuk yang ditampilkan di layar untuk beberapa pilihan
vektor s0 sampai s N minus satu dan beberapa pilihan bilangan bulat positif n. Dan izinkan saya mencatat secara eksplisit bahwa ini
bukan harus vektor unit. Satu cara untuk mendapatkan ekspresi seperti ini adalah dari teorema spektral untuk matriks semi-definit positif
yang dibahas dalam pelajaran sebelumnya. Di sini kita tidak melihat nilai eigen yang muncul secara eksplisit seperti yang kita miliki dalam dekomposisi spektral,
tapi ingat bahwa nilai eigen dari matriks semi-definit positif selalu merupakan bilangan real non-negatif, dan juga ingat bahwa kita
tidak mengharuskan vektor-vektor s0 sampai s N minus satu ini menjadi vektor unit. Jadi yang bisa kita lakukan adalah mengambil akar kuadrat dari
nilai eigen dan mengalikannya dengan vektor eigen unit yang kita dapatkan dari dekomposisi spektral untuk mendapatkan
vektor-vektor s0 sampai s N minus satu ini. Sebenarnya tidak penting untuk pembuktian ini bahwa vektor-vektor ini ortogonal — kita memang
mendapatkannya dari dekomposisi spektral, tapi kita tidak akan menggunakannya di sini. Dan kalau kita punya ekspresi J fi yang berbeda seperti ini yang tidak berasal dari teorema spektral,
itu juga tidak masalah. Kita sekarang mengurai setiap vektor ini seperti yang ditampilkan di layar, dan
ini seperti yang akan kita lakukan kalau vektor-vektor ini adalah vektor keadaan kuantum dari pasangan sistem XY dan kita sedang
melakukan pengukuran basis standar pada sistem X. Untuk memperjelas, kita tidak mengukur apa-apa di sini — kita hanya menuliskan vektor-vektor dalam bentuk ini yang
selalu memungkinkan. Dan sekarang datanglah triknya. Kita mendefinisikan Kraus matrix a0 sampai a n minus satu dengan mengambil K
A dari bagian depan vektor-vektor s0 sampai s N minus satu ini, membalikkannya sehingga mereka menjadi bra A bukan ket A,
dan menempelkannya di sisi kanan sebagaimana ditunjukkan dalam persamaan di layar. Satu cara untuk memikirkan
ini adalah bahwa kita pada dasarnya melipat vektor-vektor ini untuk membentuk matriks, sehingga kalau kita menumpuk kolom-kolom dari AK di atas satu sama lain kita akan
kembali mendapatkan s. Jadi matriks-matriks ini memiliki entri yang persis sama dengan vektor-vektor yang berkoresponden, tapi kita hanya
mengatur ulang entri-entri secara berbeda sehingga kita mendapatkan matriks. Tapi kita juga bisa memikirkan matriks-matriks ini secara murni simbolis dalam hal notasi Dirac
seperti yang ditulis di sini. Dan sekarang pada titik ini ada pertanyaan yang jelas: mengapa ini harus berhasil? Mari kita tidak terlalu lama
memikirkan mengapa berhasil — mari kita hanya verifikasi bahwa itu benar. Untuk melakukan ini, mari kita definisikan pemetaan baru yang merupakan pemetaan yang didefinisikan oleh
matriks-matriks ini di mana kita memperlakukan mereka sebagai Kraus matrix. Yang sekarang bisa kita lakukan adalah menghitung representasi Choi dari
pemetaan baru ini dan kita akan melihat bahwa itu sama dengan representasi Choi dari pemetaan fi yang kita mulai, dan
karena representasi Choi bersifat faithful, ini berarti bahwa kedua pemetaan tersebut sebenarnya sama. Saya tidak akan membahas aljabar dalam video ini —
kamu bisa memverifikasinya sendiri. Ini cukup mekanis dan merupakan latihan yang baik, dan semua yang kamu butuhkan untuk itu ada tepat
di sini di layar. Kita belum mengatakan apa-apa tentang kondisi kedua dalam dua kotak, tapi ternyata
keduanya setara, dan satu cara untuk menetapkan itu adalah memverifikasi persamaan yang ditampilkan di sini di bagian bawah
layar. Huruf T di sini omong-omong merujuk pada transposisi matriks, yang bisa kamu pikirkan secara alternatif sebagai
pemetaan linear yang mengubah ket a bra b menjadi ket b bra a, dan itu hanya sesuatu yang diperlukan untuk membuat rumusnya bekerja. Jadi
singkatnya, ada aljabar yang pasti diperlukan untuk implikasi ini, tapi seperti yang saya katakan semuanya cukup mekanis —
pada dasarnya akrobat indeks seperti yang sebagian orang menyebutnya. Tapi kalau kamu mengerjakannya dan memberi otakmu kesempatan untuk mencernanya, kamu mungkin merasa
mendapatkan pemahaman yang lebih baik tentang bagaimana representasi Choi dan representasi Kraus berhubungan. Implikasi ketiga memungkinkan kita
untuk beralih dari representasi Kraus dari pemetaan fi di mana kondisi biasa berlaku ke representasi Stinespring. Yang satu ini cukup
mirip dalam semangat dengan implikasi sebelumnya dalam artian bahwa itu mekanis dan bisa dilihat dan diverifikasi dalam istilah aljabar murni.
Idenya sebenarnya cukup sederhana. Yang bisa kita lakukan adalah mengambil Kraus matrix kita dan membentuk bagian dari matriks yang lebih besar dengan menumpuk
mereka di atas satu sama lain seperti yang ditampilkan di layar. Setelah diisi, ini akan memberi kita matriks unitary U untuk
representasi Stinespring. Matriks unitary harus berupa matriks persegi jadi kita harus mengisi sejumlah
kolom yang tersisa yang kita butuhkan untuk melakukan itu, tapi sebenarnya tidak ada bedanya apa isinya asalkan kita mendapatkan matriks
unitary. Kalau kita sejenak mengabaikan kekhawatiran bahwa U bersifat unitary dan hanya fokus pada pemetaan linear yang didefinisikan oleh
representasi Stinespring yang kita dapatkan dari matriks U ini, maka yang kita temukan adalah bahwa pemetaan itu sama dengan
pemetaan fi asli yang didefinisikan oleh representasi Kraus yang kita mulai. Itu adalah bagian lain dari pembuktian yang tidak akan saya bahas dalam video ini — kamu bisa
menemukan detailnya dalam konten tertulis untuk pelajaran ini, tapi kamu juga mungkin ingin meluangkan waktu dan mengerjakannya sendiri. Ingat saja
seperti biasa untuk seri ini bahwa kita menggunakan konvensi pengurutan ket, jadi W dan G akan
berkoresponden dengan faktor tensor di sisi kiri dalam persamaan. Dan omong-omong kalau kamu memang
mengerjakannya, kamu akan menemukan bahwa karena kita punya ket 0 bra 0 sebagai faktor tensor di sisi kiri dalam persamaan,
satu-satunya bagian dari U yang relevan adalah bagian yang diberikan oleh Kraus matrix. Jadi selama kita mengisi
kolom-kolom dari U dengan cara yang membuatnya unitary kita baik-baik saja. Tapi tentu saja ini mengharuskan kolom-kolom yang dibentuk oleh a0 sampai a n minus
satu ketika kita menumpuk mereka di atas satu sama lain bersifat ortonormal, dan di sinilah kondisi yang kita tempatkan pada representasi Kraus berperan.
Dan memang itu setara tepat dengan kolom-kolom yang bersifat ortonormal. Hubungan matematis yang relevan yang diperlukan untuk menarik
kesimpulan ini ditampilkan di bawah di layar. Jadi silakan jeda dan verifikasi kalau kamu mau, atau sekali lagi
konsultasikan konten tertulis untuk detail lebih lanjut. Singkatnya, apa yang terjadi di sini dalam implikasi ini maupun dalam
implikasi sebelumnya adalah bahwa kita mendeskripsikan operasi matematis yang sama dengan cara yang berbeda tapi setara.
Inti dari semuanya pada dasarnya adalah perkalian matriks. Implikasi keempat dan terakhir menetapkan bahwa kalau kita punya
representasi Stinespring untuk beberapa pemetaan maka pemetaan itu pasti merupakan channel yang valid, dan seperti yang saya tunjukkan
sebelumnya, kita sudah membahas implikasi ini ketika kita mendiskusikan representasi Stinespring. Singkatnya, dan dalam
WEBVTT
istilah yang sedikit berbeda: memperkenalkan sistem workspace yang sudah diinisialisasi adalah channel yang valid. Itu karena men-tensor sebuah density matrix
yang tetap ke density matrix yang diberikan selalu memberi kita density matrix, dan itu adalah pemetaan linear berdasarkan bilinearitas
dari hasil kali tensor. Operasi unitary selalu merupakan channel yang valid seperti yang saya bahas sebelumnya dalam pelajaran. Trace out sebuah sistem adalah channel yang valid karena
partial trace adalah pemetaan linear yang selalu mengubah density matrix menjadi density matrix. Dan akhirnya, komposisi dari
channel-channel selalu merupakan channel, yang cukup sederhana tapi pasti layak untuk diamati sendiri. Dan dengan
empat implikasi yang baru saja kita bahas, kita telah menetapkan kesetaraan dari tiga representasi channel kita bersama dengan
definisi asli dari sebuah channel. Khususnya kita mulai dengan definisi sebuah channel, kita melihat bagaimana definisi itu mengimplikasikan bahwa representasi Choi-nya
pasti memenuhi dua kondisi dasar. Kemudian kita melihat bagaimana kondisi-kondisi tersebut memungkinkan kita untuk menemukan representasi Kraus yang pada gilirannya
memungkinkan kita untuk menemukan representasi Stinespring, dan akhirnya kita melihat bahwa keberadaan representasi Stinespring mengungkapkan bahwa kita memang
punya channel yang valid. Tentu saja ada detail teknis di sana dan tidak harus mudah terutama
ketika kamu melihatnya untuk pertama kalinya, tapi yang menarik dan layak dicatat di sini adalah bahwa implikasi-implikasi ini diatur dengan cara yang memang
membuat segalanya semudah mungkin, dan dalam matematika kamu tidak perlu merasa malu untuk mengambil jalan yang mudah. Misalnya,
sama sekali tidak jelas bahwa setiap channel punya representasi Stinespring atau representasi Kraus,
tapi relatif mudah untuk menyimpulkan bahwa representasi Choi dari setiap channel memenuhi dua kondisi yang telah kita asosiasikan dengannya, dan itu
memungkinkan kita untuk mengikuti jalur yang lebih atau kurang aljabar ke dua representasi lainnya. Dalam nada yang sama,
implikasi terakhir dari representasi Stinespring kembali ke definisi juga relatif mudah dan
memungkinkan kita untuk menyimpulkan bahwa kita hanya mendapatkan channel dan tidak ada pemetaan lain dari representasi Choi asalkan
kondisi yang diperlukan terpenuhi. Dan seperti yang sudah saya singgung sebelumnya, cara kita berargumen tentang implikasi-implikasi ini cukup mekanis untuk memungkinkan kita dengan mudah mengkonversi
antara representasi-representasi, dan kalau kamu kembali ke beberapa contoh yang kita bahas sebelumnya dalam pelajaran, kamu akan menemukan bahwa memang mungkin untuk
mengkonversi antara representasi-representasi, kadang-kadang cukup mudah dan langsung. Dan itulah akhir dari
pelajaran ini yang seluruhnya tentang channel. Kita membahas apa itu channel dan melihat beberapa contoh dasar. Kita mendiskusikan tiga cara channel bisa
direpresentasikan dan kita menyelami beberapa detail teknis yang menetapkan kesetaraan dari representasi-representasi ini.
Semoga kamu akan bergabung dengan saya untuk pelajaran berikutnya yang seluruhnya tentang pengukuran dalam formulasi umum dari informasi kuantum. Sampai jumpa lagi!